Basic science represents curiosity.
We decided to break it up into distinct disciplines
like biology,
chemistry and astronomy.
But ultimately,
it's all the same kind of curiosity,
which is how do things work?
How did they begin? How do they end?
That is essential
to the nature of what it means to be human.
Science is about thinking
and new ways of seeing things.
Maybe there are things
that we've actually described in the same way
for a thousand years,
and then all of a sudden
we find some discovery or some realization
that says we've got to completely rethink
the way that we actually consider this.
Science does that more succinctly
than almost any other kind of human endeavor.
And so every bit as much
as we appreciate art or poetry,
we appreciate science.
Yale, it's an absolutely fabulous place for scholarship.
Its history is based on
learning and discovery.
That's why we're here.
Yale is an intellectual hub.
It is a place that has
a strong legacy of originating
some of the most exciting new ideas.
Our mission is to create new knowledge
and to transmit that knowledge
through our teaching.
The thrill of saying,
"I have this question
about how the world works.
Nobody knows the answer.
I'm going to go out
and I'm going to design the experiment
or collect the data
or develop the theory
that answers that question
and that pushes the boundaries
of human knowledge."
There's nothing like it.
Much of science is laborious.
It's called a 'laboratory' for a reason.
And it's also very time-consuming.
It takes a while
before we can actually see the importance
of these things that we do.
And in fact, what really is happening
is that we're doing the slow process
of thinking things through.
Science is unpredictable.
And I'd like to think that institutions
such as ours
offer the space for the more creative,
unpredictable kind of work
where we don't know
what the outcome is going to be.
You want to be fearless
and not constrained by current thinking.
If we're curious,
but we're not actually ambitious
and we're not brave enough
to sort of step outside of our comfort zone,
then in fact, we probably won't succeed
in making real progress.
The big leaps forward, the big discoveries,
they often start
by someone who had a very specific question
about a very specific system or process
and in the course of answering that,
opened up this whole new vista for us.
These projects are very granular,
but that is how the frontiers of knowledge expand.
When you're the first one
to actually see something
and you know that you're the first human being
to know that this is how it works...
That's an incomparable experience.
It's exciting.
It's really incredible
to have the opportunity to do what I do.
But it also tends to have, years down the road,
these unexpected payoffs
in which people had no idea
that this simple discovery was going to
actually be applied in an area
that's very, very different than what they
had assumed.
Without the foundational work
that comes out of basic sciences,
there is no applied science.
There is no technology.
Curiosity-driven research at Yale and beyond
has underpinned
almost every technological advance
that you can think of,
from food production to heating and cooling, to GPS,
to diagnostic medical imaging.
We're talking about scientific research.
What we're actually talking about is
an investment into the future.
It's an almost guaranteed thing.
People understand that
the stock market goes up and down,
but generally over time
your investment is going to pay off
and that is certainly the case with science.
A basic scientist tries to understand
the world we live in.
We seek the truth,
we seek knowledge
because there's just so much out there
to know.
Right now,
in Yale's Faculty of Arts and Sciences,
fundamental research is being done
that will end up transforming
our understanding of human health and disease,
of neuroscience,
of the quantum world,
and beyond.